in a drive against Democratic New Deal
opponents the president at barnesville
Georgia opposes senator George some have
given lip service lip service to some of
the objectives but I've not raised their
little fingers actively to attain the
objectives themselves those FDR on the
campaign trail back in 1938 railing
against opponents of his new deal
economic reform he claimed big business
was refusing to create jobs to destroy
his new deal he also blamed Wall Street
for many of the nation's economic woes
does that sound a little familiar might
might to some of us our next guest says
the president will use similar messages
in the campaign for 2012 and has already
started in fact home Reno is a professor
of history at Hillsdale College so
professor we kind of just went on the
surface there at dig a little deeper for
us you're the historian why do you see
these comparisons between FDR and the
president as far as their campaign goes
well FDR and Obama were both confronted
with a double-dip recession Roosevelt
had been elected in 1932 and he was able
to blame the depression on his
predecessor Herbert Hoover but in 1937
we had the so-called Roosevelt recession
and I think some of the methods that
Roosevelt views in attacking plutocrats
and going after the one percent of his
day President Obama finds himself in a
similar situation with an intractable
economic problem you mentioned in your
article in The Wall Street Journal the
Browns scared that we all know about the
Red Scare but very few of us know about
the brown scary tell us a little bit
about that I think our viewers will be
curious to know about it during the
1930s although I've met many people have
pointed out that some early New Deal
measures were themselves pretty similar
to those of the fascists the
corporatists in Italy in Germany by the
late 1930s Roosevelt had taken to
accusing his political enemies of being
fascists you had a clip just before of
Roosevelt going after senator Walter
George of Georgia when he was trying to
purge the Democratic Party and that term
was used as being sort of redolent of
what
learn Stalin were doing the Roosevelt
tried to turn anti-fascist sentiments in
the public against his against his
political enemies and the historian Lea
Ruffo has referred to this as the the
brown scare and it's been forgotten in
the aftermath of the the Cold War red
scares but the Liberals were attempting
to use domestic fear of foreign fascism
for political purposes did it work i
mean the fear that you mentioned for FDR
the fear of big business or vilifying
Wall Street did it work for him I know
in fact it probably saved the Republican
Party in the nineteen thirty-eight
midterm elections the party was just
about extinct and they want about 80
seats in the House of Representatives
and it really backfired so badly that it
brought the New Deal to uh to an end it
was combined of course with Roosevelt's
attack on the Supreme Court in 1937 his
attempt to purge the party this
vilification of a big business it made
roosevelt looked like he was a potential
dictator it's very interesting you point
out in your article as well that he had
to go out in public who say that he
didn't want to be a dictator he didn't
want to do that in order to quiet the
fear and the public that maybe that's
what he that's what he wanted it's
interesting to take a time out just to
look at history for this moment
professor nice to have you I thank you
for taking the time to join us today
thank